temps 39 kilos de plutonium ont été
découverts au lieu des huit que l'on
pensait trouver dans un atelier du site
nucléaire de cadarache dans le
département des bouches du rhône plus
qu'une surprise information tombe comme
un pavé dans la mare d'ailleurs semer de
s'expliquer la directrice de l'agencé
nationale pour la gestion des déchets
radioactifs sera entendue à l'assemblée
yann fossurier marque savinaud voici
l'atelier de technologie du plutonium de
cadarache tels qu'ils fonctionnaient en
2004 pendant plus de 40 ans on a
fabriqué ici du mox un combustible pour
réacteurs nucléaires à base d'uranium et
de plutonium
cette unité est aujourd'hui fermé ses
installations en cours de démantèlement
mais en juin dernier pendant les
opérations de nettoyage 39 kilos de
poussières de plutonium ont été
récupérés au lieu des 8 kg estimés par
le commissariat à l'énergie atomique
une erreur d'évaluation sans conséquence
selon le responsable du site cas aucun
problème la matière est sous contrôle
n'a pas été perdu par été volatilisées
ou pas été utilisé à d'autres fins mais
pour l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
il y a un problème car il n'a été averti
de cette anomalie que la semaine
dernière
le gendarme du nucléaire a donc décidé
de suspendre immédiatement le
démantèlement en cours à cadarache en
raison du risque représenté par cette
poussière radioactive qui s'est amassée
dans des boîtes à gants comme celle ci
quand on accumule trop de matières
fissiles en l'occurrence de plutonium
dans un même endroit il ya un risque que
certaines conditions démarre ce qu'on
appelle une réaction de criticité qui va
conduire à une émission de rayonnement
quantité importante et qui va faire
courir un risque essentiellement pour
les travailleurs le commissariat à
l'énergie atomique qui exploite le site
de cadarache estime ne rien avoir à se
reprocher il dit avoir prévenu
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire dès le
mois de juin par téléphone
l'inspecteur assermenté à qui l'on a
téléphoné au début du mois de juin donc
pour le prévenir de cette procédure que
nous mettions en place hier il ne se
souvenait même plus de notre appel donc
c'est vous dire que pour lui ça devait
pas être à l'enjeu majeur pour les
antinucléaires
cette affaire est révélatrice de graves
dysfonctionnements on est dans un écran
de fumée permanent nous fait croire que
tout ça c'est bien géré et qu'il ya du
recyclage etc
en fait tout cela c'est comme on dirait
c'est fribourg la secrétaire d'état à
l'écologie chantal jouanno a jugé de son
côté l' incident scandaleux et
inadmissible